good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to Barnes Noble Astor Place
tonight I have the distinct pleasure of
introducing Dave siren mr. siren is the
editor of the Prince George's post and
writes a weekly column for the paper
called edges sports
he's the regular sports commentator for
air America's national radio show on the
real with Chuck D and in addition he's a
senior writer at basketball calm and
regular comm lists for slam magazine his
journalism has appeared in the source
the College Sporting News the San
Francisco Bay View and Z Magazine to
name a few
and he joins us as evening to discuss
his first book what's my name fool
sports and resistance in the United
States
Mary Radcliffe author of the San
Francisco Bay View has said of the
author he is that rarest of commodities
in sports writing an original voice this
book will be loved by both athletes and
by who hate politics and by activists
who hate sports so won't you please join
me in welcoming Dave siren
what's my name fool sports and
resistance in the United States now this
book just to make it clear in one
sentence is about times when radical
politics found expression in the world
of professional sports in the u.s. now
just to be clear I have heard some of
the jokes about this book like radical
politics and us sports that'll make a
great pamphlet and why don't you just
write about something that has a little
bit more material to it like the great
atheists of the Christian Coalition or
Strom Thurmond's favorite black history
moments now but there is a tradition and
that's the case I make with this book
deeply hidden of times when the
struggles off the field exploded on to
the field with absolutely electric
consequences now this tradition runs
counter to the carnival of reaction that
I think a lot of us see in sports who
watch it on a day-in day-out basis
whether that's for work or not and in
this country now I actually had a
front-row seat for this carnival of
reaction just last month when I went to
a Washington Nationals game that's my
home team and I went because you know
big shock I actually wanted to see a
baseball game but instead what I was
treated to was what the Nationals were
calling Military Appreciation Night or
man where 20 young men right there at
the home plate and emphasis on men were
sworn in to the US Marines before the
start of the game now this took place
with George W Bush sitting in one of the
owners boxes up top as you know like
Caesar you know I kept waiting for lions
to emerge from the dugout as the
announcer thanked Bush and the troops
for fighting for our freedom in Iraq and
honestly i sat there just slack-jawed
which is not my normal pose just utterly
speechless not my normal mode of action
because I mean as fans I mean this is
when the speechless part came we were
informed by that kind of disembodied god
voice that comes from the speakers that
we too could sign up to fight for opera
Araki freedom at a stand located right
outside the stadium Wow peanuts Cracker
Jacks in war that is a great evening if
I ever heard one now
if like me you're one of the you know
61% of the country who doesn't think
that the troops in Iraq happened to be
fighting for freedom right now you find
yourself in this stadium with absolutely
no voice you find yourself with no way
to express yourself to the athletic
industrial complex and I was sitting
there and it's just it just never ceases
to amaze me how sports something that
had a huge role in shaping me growing up
something that was an incredibly
positive influence on me growing up that
I believed should celebrate beauty and
the best of competition and cooperation
and fun god forbid can be used in such a
disgusting way now I love sports and
that's why I think we need to fight for
sports we need to actually reclaim them
we need to take sports back and if we're
gonna do so what we need is we need to
know our history that's our greatest
ammunition in this fight we need to know
our history of the athletes the sports
writers and the fans who have stood up
to the machine if for no other reason
than knowing this history I think allows
us to look at the world and see that
struggle can affect every aspect of life
in this system even the swoosh adorned
ivory tower known as sports now I want
to start here really by talking about
where the title of this book comes from
and I'd to be honest I used to have a
joke that clunked mightily when I would
when I would talk about the book where I
would say what's my name fool no it's
not a tribute to mr. t which only had
that kind of reaction and um but but
what occurred to me it was I was
actually at a bookstore a couple weeks
ago when a young well-meaning person
came up to me and said oh my god is this
the book about mr. T and was totally
serious so I repeat that just to say
that our history has been robbed from us
I think is a safe assessment and I want
to start though about where this title
actually comes from because I think it
tells a great deal about the book and
it's also a direct reference to what I
believe is the high points of that
connection between sports and resistance
which in my view is the time
when the heavyweight champion of the
world had one foot in the black freedom
struggle and one foot in the anti-war
movement and of course I'm talking about
the great Muhammad Ali now today in 2005
I think people especially people who are
say under 30 you know know Ali most is
sort of like the walking sane the guy
who lit the torch at the 96 Olympics in
Atlanta the guy who comes out to throw
out the first pitch or toss the ball and
when you see this and you see presidents
sort of pat him on the back and lead him
by the hands you just would never know
that this was the most despised
slandered brutalized and also heroic
athlete on the face of the earth in the
1960s now Ali made everybody confront
his politics of resistance when he
changed his name
first from Cassius Clay to Cassius X
actually and then of course to Muhammad
Ali and if we're gonna talk about Ali
just to be very clear everybody has to
get Will Smith out of their heads
because it's just too upsetting to me to
think that people are The Fresh Prince
of Bel Air is moving on okay now there
are really no words for the storm that
this caused when Cassius Clay changed
his name I mean the heavyweight champion
of the world in this country in the 60s
when boxing was arguably the biggest
sport in the United States the champion
was the symbol of Americana red white
and blue strength power aggression all
of these things and all of a sudden you
had the heavyweight champion of the
world first of all talking about how
pretty he was which shocked people you
know in and of itself but then joining
the organization of Malcolm X joining an
organization in the nation of islam that
unabashedly believed in self-defense for
people fighting in the south and the
civil rights movement and the mobs up
corrupt right wing fight world
absolutely lost their minds but what was
incredible about that time was overnight
whether you the name became so seminal
to the 60s because whether or not you
called the champion clay or ally it said
everything about you it said what side
you were on in the black freedom
struggle what side you were on in the
free speech movements breaking out on
campuses soon the war in Vietnam as well
it was an incredible thing and just to
give an idea about this my step aunts
was was telling me this story when I was
showing her
book about how she actually moved out of
her apartment for a week where you know
living with her dad she's 17 years old
she moved out and stayed on a friend's
couch because she got in this huge fight
with her dad about whether the
heavyweight champions name happened to
be clay or happened to be ollie now you
might think that this sounds like a
pretty dysfunctional family and you'd be
right but but the bigger issue is that
it was really not an argument about his
name it was an argument about the
political period it was an argument
about the radicalization breaking out
and which side of the barricades you
might have seen yourself on now this
whole name controversy really reached
its peak in November of 1965
that's when Ali fought a former two-time
champion a man who was proudly patriotic
named Floyd Patterson now in the
pre-fight hype Patterson this is what he
said to reporters this is a direct quote
he said this fight is a crusade to
reclaim the title from the black Muslims
as a Catholic I am fighting clay and yes
his name is clay as a patriotic duty to
return the crown to America now Ally's
response to this just shocked reporters
because he had no response at all I mean
this was the man they called Louisville
lip gashes cash as cash the brash and he
had nothing to say in response to this
he just let it simmer and then he did
his talking in the ring nine rounds
against Patterson he just took him apart
and as he was jabbing at Patterson he
yelled out so everyone in press row
could hear he said come on America come
on white America say my name is my name
clay what's my name fool and that's
where I get the title of the book and
that's just the title so it's a good
book
now what's interesting is I'm talking to
people about this book I've been had the
privilege to go around and speak about
it is that most sports fans I talk to
know Ally is the person responsible for
saying what's my name fool not mr. t and
most know that it's in reference to his
name change and religious conversion
but it's the background that people
don't know the swirling black freedom
struggle the symbolic and very personal
importance Ally's fights had two people
just figuring out how to stand up on
their own I mean as bryant gumbel said
and i can't believe i'm quoting bryant
gumbel but it's a really good quote he
said one of the reasons the civil rights
movement went forward was that black
people were able to overcome their fear
and I honestly believe that for many
black Americans that came from watching
Muhammad Ali he simply refused to be
afraid and being that way he gave other
people courage and another person Julian
Bond who back then was a young civil
rights activist today's one of the heads
of the n-double a-c-p he said the act of
Ali joining the nation was not
necessarily something we all agreed with
but we just loved the fact that he
seemed to be telling white people to go
to hell for us now I want to give two
examples of that sense though about
Ali's actual presence giving people
confidence in the movements going on
outside the ring that I think are very
evocative and certainly not something
we're taught in sports century moments
on ESPN I mean the first is something
that took place in Alabama where you had
a group of african-american activists
and snick the Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee basically the
youth wing of the civil rights movement
they were organizing a group there
called the loans County Freedom Party
they're trying to register the poorest
of the poor african-american voters in
Alabama sharecroppers people who were
people who worked in factories down
there and that they're famous in this in
sort of the annals of the civil rights
movement because they were the first
people to ever use the symbol of a black
panther and Huey Newton and Bobby Seale
in California they use that as an
inspiration to call themselves the Black
Panthers that's something people who
know the history of the civil rights
movement know that oh yeah that's where
they had the symbol of the Black Panther
in Alabama but what a lot of people
don't know is that their slogan that
they had emblazoned underneath the Black
Panther was we are the greatest I mean
they took the alley I am the greatest
and put a big plural on the
front of that another example is Martin
Luther King when he came out against the
Vietnam War in 1967 this is something
that's generally talked about with King
and general discussion but it's not
remembered the degree of pressure and
criticism he received for doing it at
the time not just from like the
mainstream media but also from the
established civil rights movement who
thought that King shouldn't be speaking
out about international affairs of war
when King gave his first press
conference to actually speak about the
war in Vietnam he said in his remarks
like Muhammad Ali tells us we are all
victims of the same system of injustice
and oppression like incorporating
Muhammad Ali's name to explain why he's
coming out against the war that to me is
incredible
now I think these stories are incredible
I hope I'm not alone but I think the
problem is in sports history itself as
its told on you know the worldwide
leader ESPN is that it gets marketed to
death with the soft lighting the bad
music
the booyah all that stuff and like Ali
it becomes utterly sort of ESP ended you
know it's like it's political teeth just
get extracted and that's really what the
book is about is trying to reclaim that
history and learn about the fire
underneath the icons Nonna gives some
examples of that sort of like the
history that we know and then the
history that were not told like for
example it's it's well known that Jack
Johnson was the first black heavyweight
champion of the world winning the title
in 1908 but do we know that he when he
defended the title successfully against
Jim Jeffords who was called the great
white hope his defeat of Jeffords
actually started the greatest race riot
this country had ever seen and ever
would see until the 1968 King
assassination the character of these
riots were white mobs incensed at
Johnson's victory attempting to enter
black neighborhoods and and black
communities defending themselves by
force after a boxing match this occurred
in 1910 I mean and just some continue
that just to show how like what happens
off the field or out of the ring
influences what's in the ring
Booker T Washington who was just
outraged and Senseo conservative black
leader at the time went to Johnson and
demanded that he condemned people for
rioting and
Johnson said you can kiss my I can't say
that cuz on TV but but Johnson responded
you can kiss my black ass is what
Johnson said in response I just got the
OK from c-span okay I mean we may also
know that that baseball what was
segregated for 50 years until 1947 but
do we know the story of Lester red
Rodney who was the sports editor of the
Communist Party's newspaper The Daily
Worker I mean a lot of people I talked
to their first response is Wow that the
Daily Worker had a sports section that's
the first point of surprise but that
Lester Rodney used the sports section as
an organizing center to fight for
baseball's integration a campaign that
garnered over a million signatures
collected at ballparks around the
country from Wrigley Field to Comiskey
Park to Yankee Stadium out here in New
York now I I got to interview Lester
Rodney for this book and it was an
absolute privilege and something that I
will never ever forget and 95 years old
Sharpe is attack I mean we may know that
Jackie Robinson was that man the first
one to integrate baseball in 1947 but I
think we know him mostly as this kind of
quiet suffering black Saint who was
brought to the Dodgers under the sort of
paternal warmth of Branch Rickey now
what we don't know him as is a person
who wrote a political sports column for
the New York Post which dealt with the
issues of civil rights and this is when
the New York Post was not something you
use to wipe your floor but actually was
a liberal publication and we also don't
know him as he was the the number one
requested Speaker of the n-double a-c-p
in the United States at that time in the
1950s and he barnstormed around the
country speaking at meetings the number
to speaker at the time was someone you
might have heard of named Martin Luther
King and went when the way Robinson
would wrap up his speeches is he would
always use this one line that people
would go nuts he would say if I had to
choose between the Hall of Fame and full
citizenship for my people I would choose
full citizenship time and again and that
to me is like almost like instinctually
like the best tradition of the left in
this country like when former labor
labor leader and Socialist Party
candidate Eugene Debs would say when I
rise it's going to be with the ranks not
from the ranks that's what I hear in
Robinson's words and it's I think it's
incredible we may know for example about
the fame
Black Power salute of Tommie Smith and
John Carlos at the 1968 Olympics I mean
you can go outside probably and buy it
on a t-shirt I mean it's even being
commemorated last month it was
commemorated in a statue in California
but there's a lot about that picture we
don't know and it's one of the most
marketed pictures certainly in the last
hundred years but we don't know that
Tommie Smith and John Carlos they also
wore beads on the medal stand to protest
lynching they didn't wear shoes because
they wanted to protest poverty that John
Carlos actually wore his Olympic jacket
open which was a massive breach of
etiquette at the time that shocked them
almost as much as the fist thing and
when I got to interview John Carlos for
the book and when I asked him why he
left his jacket open he said quote I
wanted it open because I wanted to
represent shift workers blue-collar
people in the underdogs the people whose
contributions to society are so
important but don't get recognized and
we certainly don't hear about the
instances that were occurring around
these guys in 1968 that led to that
moment you know the assassination of dr.
King and how it influenced those guys to
make a stand at the Olympics you know
the strikes in May in Paris the movement
that was occurring in South Africa at
the time against apartheid which was
very influential to Smith and Carlos and
of course the assassination of 500
students and workers in Mexico City
right before the Olympics by the state
police as they attempted to make Mexico
City safe for the Olympic Games and so
we hear that we see the picture but we
don't hear any of the history which to
me is the equivalent of like telling the
story of the Titanic and forgetting the
iceberg I mean it's bad history it's bad
politics and it's it's I think generally
bad writing as well to put it bluntly
okay women I need some water
possibly I got personal credit
this book about like the underdog and
whatnot I'm like hey you on the crutches
get me some water that wouldn't be that
would be terrible I mean moving on we
may know about Billie Jean Kings battle
of the sexes match against Bobby Riggs
one of the most watched television
programs in the history of this country
but whenever they do retrospectives of
that we don't hear about how deeply
embedded that match was at the time with
the movement for women's liberation
especially one of the most enduring
victories of that movement and that's a
title nine at legislation which which
ensured equal funding even though it's
it's largely unenforced but still an
incredible victory that allows women
equal funding not just for sports it's
commonly thought of as just a sports
thing but also educational opportunities
in general I think we need to know this
history because it's a living history
and it's alive anytime athletes today
attempt to use their hyper exalted
commercialize platform to speak out on
social issues or draw inspiration from
struggles in the streets this history is
alive when Carlos Delgado who's a
slugger for the Florida Marlins when he
was playing for the Toronto Blue Jays
last year said he wouldn't stand on the
steps for the American flag because the
war in Iraq was quote unquote murder
based upon lies it's alive when the
NBA's etan thomas who plays for the
washington wizards shows up at
anti-death-penalty events in DC to read
a slam poetry that calls out the racism
of this system in utterly stark terms
and people should check out his book of
poetry called more than an athlete which
will absolutely blow your mind it's
alive when felipe alou who's the manager
of the San Francisco Giants stands up to
the anti-immigrant racism on sports
radio and does it proudly it's al and I
think it's especially alive when the US
Congress and their steroid hysteria
hoopla you know kind of like
like Joe McCarthy's like little cousin
stuff you know it's it's ridiculous
feared calling Barry Bonds to testify on
steroids out of concern that he would
say to them what he'd been saying to
reporters namely quote why is steroids
cheating but making a shirt in Korea for
50 cents and selling it here for a
hundred and fifty dollars isn't now
knowing this history positions
to support and embrace not just the
athletes to go out on a political limb
but also fans who thrill to their
exploits and I think by confronting
these messages that are pumped out
through our play we can dissect what we
like and what we dislike about sports
and then challenge not only sports but
also our society to change I mean when
war planes fly overhead as they do
before Baltimore Ravens games in my neck
of the woods we can actually ask how
many physical education classes are cut
to pay for every Blue Angel when those
disgustingly sexist beer commercials
trade on women's oppression for the high
cause of selling beer we can make clear
that this kind of stuff has no place in
sports when college athletes are just
massacred in the media for taking
under-the-table payoffs we can ask about
like whose blood sweat and tears
actually paid for that new and norma
Dome on that campus when announcers on
Fox become like as a ghast is like
Southern Belles when they see a
touchdown dance get too raunchy I mean
we can ask how a network that pays Bill
O'Reilly millions and promotes shows
like who's your daddy and the littlest
groom which is a I don't want to say
what that's about but it's kind of gross
but how they have the right to be the
purity police when our cities like this
city are attempted to be soaked by
sleazy Stadium deals like the Rat House
by Bruce Ratner that he's trying to
build in Brooklyn we can stand up as
sports fans and say hey we may love
baseball we may love basketball it might
be nice to have the nets in town
what-have-you but I'm not gonna give a
billionaire a 350 million dollar present
for the privilege of watching it now by
speaking out for the political soul of
the sports we love we do more than just
build a fighting left that stands for
social justice in every arena we also
begin to impose our own ideas on the
world of sports a counter morality to
compete with the yawning hypocrisy of
the pro leagues and to me these are this
is a morality that allows us to thrill
to Barry Bonds to not give up sports
just because they soak it with their
ideas to thrill to Michael Vick to
thrill to Mia Hamm kicking a soccer ball
but unlike the mainstream sports Jabbar
it's a morality that actually recognizes
these athletes as human beings with
minds as well as bodies not just as
extensions of equipment I think it needs
to understand that the incent
of athletes to speak out for social
justice lies not in their individual
brilliance but aren't our ability to
build a struggle outside the arena in
other words if we want more Muhammad
Ali's more John Carlos's and more Billie
Jean Kings if we want to see a gay male
athlete have the courage to risk his
neck by coming out instead of players
like Mike Piazza calling press
conferences just to let us all know that
he's not gay I think that's gonna take
building a broader movement for social
justice outside the arena so our heroes
will have people to look up to and in
that fight we need every drop of history
we can get our hands on as Tommie Smith
himself said about his famed Black Power
salute it's not something this is what
Tommy Smith said he said quote it's not
something I could lay on my shelf and
forget about my heart and soul are still
on that team and I still believe in
everything we were trying to fight for
in 1968 it has not been resolved and
it's going to be part of our future
I mean he's absolutely right struggle is
part of our future and when that
struggle occurs it will affect and is
affecting right now athletes and fans
alike what the book is about at the end
of the day is it's about knowing that
those who speak out actually stand in a
tradition that goes back a hundred years
and that speaks to actually beyond the
field of play to all of us it's
tradition that stands in the broader
fight for social justice it's tradition
we should embrace whether we're sports
fans or not thank you
[Music]
hey we're taking questions I'll remind
people that were on TV wait for the mic
makeups in the back if people want to
now just get just raise your hand I've
been I've been mulling on this question
for about ten years so I'm happy I've
been really looking forward to being
here I read I can't think of a better
place for you to ask I read your article
in the international socialist review
about the Jack Johnson riots and so the
I remember in 1992 when I was in I guess
I was a freshman in high school
the Chicago the dirt when the Chicago
Bulls first won the NBA championship
though I mean I remember just seeing on
TV you know Rodney the the Rodney King
trial verdict that just happened there
had just been the rebellion in Los
Angeles so I remember seeing on TV that
after the Bulls won fans rushed to the
VIP like end of the stadium because I
think the Chicago stadium is on the poor
side of town they they were I mean you
know assaulting the limousines and all
the important people they were burning
police cars I mean it was you know there
was a little rebellion going on and so
basically my question and and I haven't
I've tried since the advent of the
internet to look this up and I just
basically want to ask about like given
the fact that the Chicago Police are
like racist and brutal like what is it
about that that allows these little
opportunities for people to fight back
and such a you know you know I don't
know a victorious way where they you
know you know they won they drove the
cops away and and like do you know of
anything else I don't know in world
sports history even where there was some
political I know advanced after a sports
victory or defeat I mean as far as world
sports I'm not just sports take place
outside the United States I'm sorry I'm
I'm a born and I'm a born and raised in
this country so I've never heard of
these others but now I'm just um I mean
it means I yeah I'm not going to take
the pro sports
stance as a mode for social change but
but but just to say that when sports
riots do occur I mean I do think that
obviously like you don't go out and burn
a limousine if you're feeling really
good about your life and your options
and what what's going on in the world I
mean so I think that they are largely if
not entirely expressions of alienation I
mean whether they occur on college
campuses or occur in cities that doesn't
mean necessarily even that they're
politically progressive in any way I
think their their expressions though I
mean it's not a good thing like I had
somebody like once said a meeting asked
me like hey I was at Syracuse University
and there was this riot after we won the
championship how do we channel that into
the movement against the war and it's
like what you don't
I mean it's summer so it's an expression
of people's utter sort of disconnection
from politics not an expressed not an
expression of their connection I mean
it's more like an outgrowth of just
anger and frustration that people feel
not an expression of I think even
something positive that we can organize
I think the Jack Johnson thing is
different because it was the character
of people defending their neighborhoods
against white lynch mobs and feeling the
confidence to do that in the context of
what Jack Johnson represented against a
great white hope so I think there's a
qualitative difference there than some
guys lighting their mattress on fire in
their frat house and throwing it out in
the street not that I don't want to talk
to those guys but just when they're not
drunk I snap several questions let's
talk about the Olympics first I don't
know if you mentioned in the book I'm in
the middle of reading the book right now
but I think one summer äj-- I think his
right pronunciation he's he was the head
of the International Impa Committee on
have you brought this out but he was a
former I think education or physical
director for our Francisco Franco and I
was running with it if you know the
history historical background behind
that and how he impacted on the Olympics
and I don't know whether or not you
talked about the situation in the Bern
Olympics in 1936 were the Jewish
athletes Marty Glickman I really was one
of them that were excluded from the
Olympics participating in the 36 Berlin
Olympics is they were Jewish and whether
that you had included that in the book
itself the other the other question I
had was a transformation metamorphosis
of George Foreman because I remember
going out watching George Foreman I was
a young kid that back in the
seventy-five it was he was really quiet
and you know he's really close and
didn't say very much whereas Ally was
really boisterous and it's like a
complete metamorphosis and George
Foreman's really loud and have you
talked about that what the basis that
transformation of course Ally we know
because of his disease and because he
took too many punches probably but make
a comment on that and then one last
thing is about did your money in your
book of back in the 70s called in your
face I love you remember that book it
was a book that was a sports book that
talked about the issues that you
remember some went to that at that
period of time Wow um first first about
the Olympics and Juan Antonio Samaranch
whose name he pronounced just fine I
mean I mean he he was the head for a
long time of the International Olympic
Committee the IOC now the IOC throughout
their history in the last hundred years
I mean had more fascists sitting around
the table than like your typical
outtakes of the Nuremberg trials I mean
is an outrageous motley crew of people
who supported Franco's Spade and Hitler
I mean it's like find me a fascist these
guys were I mean they followed him
around like groupies would follow the
Grateful Dead I mean these guys are
pretty outrageous and it actually
connects very well with like kind of the
history of the Olympics so the modern
Olympics started in 1898 which was also
the year the spanish-american war in
this country and the mean it had to do
with actually organizing the divisions
of the world through games
I mean representing what was happening
in the broader sense in the world and I
do talk about that in the book but no
the modern Olympic movement it's kind of
a contradictory thing because it's like
on the one hand you actually do get to
see sports that are utterly marginalized
in the other time it's like I like
watching those sports I like not having
to watch you know the same thing all the
time and a lot of the in a lot of those
sports I think there's just incredible
beauty and and it's wonderful really I
mean the way in the state of Maryland
the way it really did come alive around
like Michael Phelps the swimmer and all
of a sudden people are talking about
swimming and that to me is interesting
and a learning stuff and it's different
especially women's sports get a Profile
in the Olympics they don't get other
times but the Olympics itself as a
quote-unquote movement and they talk
about the Olympic movement I would argue
is utterly barbaric and reactionary in
every way shape or form and if you want
proof of that you raised one example
which to me is the tip of the iceberg
and that's the 36 Olympics in Berlin the
history of when the Olympics actually go
to a place and what they do to a place
in terms of organizing a city is about
crushing a municipality and actually
crushing the people who actually live in
a given City and people in New York you
guys should give yourselves a hand for
warding off the 2000 is it 12 Olympics
you did very well for yourself and just
the last thing I'm sorry I just say
about that is one of the reasons why you
guys didn't get the Olympics is because
they were flooded with emails and phone
calls from people in New York City
saying please do not send us the
Olympics because people here had some
sense of actually what that means for
ordinary people there's a whole history
about that which we can talk about
forman I'm not going to talk about other
people have questions I'm sorry I'm
going on it's like I have a lot about
forming in the book so I got to
interview him which was really cool
especially when he started singing Bob
Dylan to me over the phone that that
everybody must get stoned song he
started singing that over the phone and
then he said you know what that songs
about and I'm like I don't know what
drugs and he's like no it's about you
know when people throw stones at you
when you make a stand and I was like I
don't know George I think it's about
drugs
I should go get stoned I mean I don't
know sorry Dave I'm wondering if there
was a pivot point that got the sports
labor movement started and if you can
tell us if the American labor movement
can learn anything from the pro sports
labor movement I mean yeah I mean first
it's an understanding that sports unions
I would argue our part of the labor
movement which is kind of a difficult
argument sometimes because you have some
athletes like Michael Jordan Magic
Johnson who are part owners of teams and
I don't care how good your union is if
you're a steel worker you're not going
to own a string of steel mills at the
end of the day so it's it's highly
distorted it's different you know
players organize individual contracts
but the whole reason why players make
their super salaries is actually because
of the fact that there was a union
movement in sports particularly in the
1960s and the pivot for that was really
to events and I talked about it
extensively in the book a whole chapter
on it one was the hiring of Marvin
Miller who was a steel workers union
organizer and I got to interview Marvin
Miller for the book and he brought a
different kind of approach to organizing
baseball players who at the time
baseball players what they made in a
year average salary in the mid-60s for a
baseball player was like low twenty
thousand at that point I mean every
player unless you were like Mickey
Mantle basically he worked in the
offseason I interviewed older players I
mean they worked in quarries in the
offseason like crushing rocks it's hard
to imagine Alex Rodriguez going to the
quarry you know but that's what the
conditions were like at the time and
they won that bigger piece of the pie
through active struggle in solidarity
and the pivot for that was Marvin Miller
in his relationship with Curt Flood
which I talk about in the book Curt
Flood was it was a different kind of
player who he represented a lot of
people in that he came from Oakland
which means he came from a city and he
was african-american growing up in
Oakland so it's like that was different
for the major leagues in the 60s because
at the time there was still a small
minority of black players and the ones
who were there tended to come from very
small towns in the south very isolated
very atomized here you had Curt Flood
coming in representing a lot of players
who were new at that time coming in and
having to play like in the
minor leagues and people would be
calling and boy and asking him to eat on
the on the bus and you know all that
stuff and he would be like who are you
talking to you know I'm from Oakland I
will kill you you know it is just like
you know it's a very different kind of
attitude that he brought to it that was
and so what he did was him and Marvin
Miller Marvin Miller the genius of
Marvin Miller was he got that the labor
movement and I think a lot of labor
leaders today need to see this does not
exist in a vacuum he got that black
workers were becoming radicalized he
talked with Curt Flood about how to
actually use that to push forward and
even though Curt Flood
I mean his story ends up being being a
tragic one but he fought to end the
reserve clause which was really the
trigger for the salaries uh spiraling
upward to where we are today and what I
agree with what I take from it all is
what one major league player about Alex
Rodriguez who so they said about him if
Alex Rodriguez has a soul he'll send 10%
of his paycheck to Curt floods family
dave is there is there any truth to the
rumor that you were on steroids when you
wrote this book that's that's not really
my question could you talk about the way
the sports world and then the ensuing
madness in the media co-opted Pat
Tillman's moved from pro football into
the US military I thought you'd say the
person who asked that questions a writer
named Mickey Z who's one of the best
writers out there if you've never heard
of him you should get his stuff I'm
sorry I just wanted to say that he's an
incredible incredible writer to answer
the first question though if I am taking
steroids there's a doctor who's gonna
get sued pretty damn quick I'll tell you
that the second part though the Pat
Tillman's story is is to me like almost
overbearingly overwhelmingly tragic and
it's one that I think is worth reviving
and talking about especially given what
cindy sheehan is doing right now in
Texas I mean Cindy
it's one of those things where you say
never let anybody tell you that one
person can't make a difference I mean if
they're willing to actually get out
there and put themselves on the line and
I mean the connection with Cindy Sheehan
has to do with Pat Tillman's parents
people know the story of Pat Tillman I'm
going to assume they do he's turned down
millions of dollars in the NFL he joined
the Army Rangers we eat we got the big
national eat he was killed in
Afghanistan there was a nationally
televised funeral that John McCain and
other quote/unquote political luminaries
spoke at Bush even spoke on the
jumbotron at the Arizona Stadium where
he played during the election season to
address the fans as everybody cheered
and they flew the Blue Angels USA USA
the only problem with it was that it was
a total unequivocal and disgusting lie
because Pat Tillman actually died at the
hands of his own troops and how that
occurred is still something that's very
unknown and and because they burned all
the evidence at the time claiming that
it was a biohazard which is actually not
true I looked it up because I had all
these people email me after I wrote
about it saying you don't understand
military law man they had to burn the
evidence it's like great you know what
love did love the laptop commandos like
what they're you know but but that but
what makes the story so just like
relentlessly disgusting was the fact
that Pat Tillman's parents were not told
that he died in this matter Pat
Tillman's brother who was in his platoon
who he went to the Rangers with was not
told and they were left at the funeral
basically being used as props so people
asked what did Pat Tillman actually die
for I mean in the literal sense he died
for PR for this war and it's also not a
coincidence at all that they needed to
sell his death as heroic because it came
out the same week as Abu Ghraib and the
scandal there they needed that story
they needed a hero and they needed
someone in Pat Tillman who couldn't turn
them down as he did when he was a live
soldier and say I'm not going to do your
ads I just want to be a soldier or
whatever you know whether they agree or
disagree with what Pat Tillman did the
point is is that they ruthlessly
exploited him in death and his parents
Pat and Mary senior after they heard
this they were both knowing very quiet
people very conservative people there on
divorced couple they
spoke out jointly about this they
condemned bush they condemn the war they
condemned just the entire charade that
their family was put through and then
they immediately got quiet again I was
really hoping that they would use that
as an opportunity but two things
happened that I thought were a shame one
was that because this story really did
get relegated to the sports section I
didn't see like the anti-war movement
the left actually go to the Tillman's
and be like let's get your story out
there let's talk about it because it
exposes how sick this system is which is
something I would argue should have
happened and the second thing but what
I'm hoping now is like with what cindy
sheehan is doing that it's going to give
a confidence and courage not just to the
Tillman's but to everybody who's lost a
family member in this disgusting war and
that includes Iraqis as well to actually
get out there and have their story heard
[Applause]
ask you about a well say something about
John Roberts for a second because one of
the things that this moderates
apparently you know very palatable
Supreme Court justice has talked about
is being against title 9 and just I was
wondering if you could just talk for me
in about like what title is actually
meant in this nation for women's sports
and like what and and maybe what it
would look like if something like that
was opposed yeah I mean first just I
mean title night it's it speaks to me I
have a 12 month year old daughter right
now so it's like when I hear about them
overturning title 9 you know I've doing
women's rights work was one of the first
political things I ever did in college
but now that I have a daughter I'm just
kind of like oh this [ __ ] just got
personal
you know what are you doing you know cuz
before Title 9 was enacted roughly one
out of let me put it this way right now
one out of every three women / girls in
the United States take part in sports on
the junior high or high school level one
out of three before Title nine it was
one out of 27 I mean you are talking
about a radical radical difference in
the lives of women because of this
legislation and if you look at it
statistically issues about
with regards to self-esteem likelihood
of being in an abusive relationship
likelihood of having an eating disorder
these things can be connected with
sports and this to me with all that's
disgusting about sports speaks to what's
good about sports because obviously
people are get something productive out
of it that does something positive for
them in their lives
if it can produce those results and this
is what John Roberts wants to destroy
not and actually what George Bush wants
to destroy as well
now why do they want to destroy it I
think they want to destroy it for not
because they dislike watching the UConn
women's hoops team you know I think they
want to destroy it for the same reason
that they want to overturn Roe vs. Wade
I mean I think they want to destroy it
for the same reason that that they're
actually trying to rollback everything
that a previous generation Ali's
generation won in the streets and I
think for that reason alone it's worth
fighting for but it's also worth
fighting for because it represents an
attack on all of us nobody benefits on
this and they put tried out all this
garbage about it about oh it's just
funding teams that don't need to be
there look at the men's crew team they
had to be you know eliminated look at
the men's wrestling team just to facts
for people to leave here with one is
that the number one budget eater in all
of college sports is football men's
football the budget for men's football
destroys athletic budgets and men's
footballs like a lottery if you roll out
a team and you happen to go 11 and 1 you
are gonna make millions and millions and
millions if you roll out a team and
you're four and seven you just created a
sieve and your budget is destroyed and
they invest on the chance of reaping
that kind of money
that's one thing the second thing is
that there is no record anywhere anytime
in history in history of a woman's team
being funded then rolling out the balls
the coach comes out with the whistle and
nobody shows up that's never happened
it shows time and again if you give
people if you give women the opportunity
to actually practice athletic arts
practice that kind of freedom of
expression with sports they will grab
that time and again Oh
Oh finally I get a wrap-up this is great
yeah my child needs shoes no um no just
kidding no I mean I'll just say really
quickly the most rewarding thing about
doing this book by a mile has been
people who've come up to me and said
like hey I was never able to have a
political discussion with my dad before
or with my daughter before with my son
before but I gave him this book and they
actually read it and now we're I mean
and now they're like hey I didn't know
this about Ollie I didn't know this
about Billie Jean King and then all of a
sudden I realize I'm talking about civil
rights with my dad I'm talking about
anti racism with my dad and it's like if
you can use sports as a way to actually
talk to people so I think we live in a
country where politics is a dirty word
it's a bad thing at my job if you're a
political to be political and I think
that's because people view politics is
what the two ugly white guys with the
bad haircuts do on c-span and not
politics is what we live and breathe
every single day and that is politics
politics are in art politics are in
culture and politics are in sports and
we should not like walk away from that
political arena we should jump in it
with two feet have out the fights and
get a new generation of people pissed
off at the system and get them to not
burn up the cars after Syracuse wins the
championship but go out there and raise
some hell about this war and about this
world thank you
[Applause]